so bigelow
bigelow is another aerospace guy he used
to own the skinwalker ranch
skinwalker rancher is a huge thing going
on with right now if you guys have been
watching that but
no what is that really interesting
skinwalker ranch is in utah it's crazy
it's crazy it's been based on
aliens ufos skin walkers are a navajo
belief
and when the utes the paiutes and the
navajos
were fighting the utes turned on the
navajos and supported
the uh the military or the the cavalry
at the time
and so the the uh
navajos were made to walk from arizona
to new mexico a lot of them died it was
so you know it's a it's an ugly story
but they said because the youth did that
to them that they created this thing
called the skinwalker
and have cursed this area well the
interesting thing is that this
particular ranch the skinwalker ranch
was owned
by several groups who've all sold it the
last guy that owned the place
ray used to raise cattle and they were
these real high-end
so he was really involved with what he
did he got to know the sheriff at the
time the sheriff was um
like like to ride as well so
one day they were talking and he said
i'm missing three of my prize heifers i
don't know whether there's somewhere
here on the farm but i don't know where
they're at they said well hey listen
let's get together saturday we'll take
the horses out we'll go ride and we'll
go find them
so they wrote all day they couldn't find
them so they came back
and he said he wanted he was i want to
go into one of the horse tables and grab
a hoof scrap
scrape to get some stuff that was in his
got caught in his horse's hoof
and he goes when he walked over to this
large uh
room and opened the door those three
cows were in there stacked on top of
each other
stacked out stacked on they were
standing on each other's backs standing
standing
uh they thought they were close to death
but the sheriff said no like
there was snot coming out of his nose
and still had like you can see the blood
i guess pumping the neck he said if you
pull them down
maybe put some water on them they might
come back to life and they did
so if they were how are they not limp
like if their legs were
uh well i don't get all the details he
just said when i opened the door the
cows were stacked on top of each other
now this is a sheriff and he's like
those the people that own the property
are obviously
they're gone they're not even around
anymore so on the show
it's just a really funny visual to see
three cows getting on top of each other
how is that alien related what is what's
so scary about that i mean other than
being weird
so that's all it takes to freak people
out is just do something a little bit
out of the ordinary
they'll see pretty out of the order yeah
well even when he got there he said he
never understood the guy had
locks on everything locks on the doors
inside locks on the doors outside locks
on the doors around the barns locks on
he goes
everything was locked up and he just
said it's a very dangerous place and
shares that i'd never you know that's
fine if that's
that's your deal then that's your deal
so on
tuesday night the nephew
of the last owner was on the show and
they were talking to him and he said
he goes so what's it like to be out
today because it's just weird because of
all the strange things that happens well
talk to us a little bit
what was really strange what was one of
the first things you saw
the guy said well hold on he goes let me
ask you about this he goes there were
three dogs who were killed out here
and the guy goes there was that day no
they were killed back in the
mid 90s okay and so he said where were
these dogs killed he goes matter of fact
they were just killed over here let's go
take a look so they walk over to this
particular area and he said so
well we had heard that they had been
killed
and the guy said well not only were they
killed they were crushed into the ground
and the guy goes like what do you mean
crushing the ground he's like something
came above the top of him and crushed
him into the ground
there was also a big burn mark all the
way around each of the dogs
on the ground the guy goes well how did
that happen he goes well hold on because
let me back up he goes
we used to see these blue uh uh orbs
and he goes we always felt they were
malevolent but we really didn't know
because we're watching a blue and bounce
down off this
mountaintop and it comes down and it
goes into the bushes and that's when our
dogs started going crazy
so the dogs chased him into the bushes
and while we heard him yelp
and when we walked inside there and the
guy goes oh so this is what you heard
and the guy said no i was
there i was there the day this all went
on he said uh
two weeks later after this event had
happened because my uncle started to
really think hey we need to get out of
here this thing's gonna kill one of us
he goes we're standing on the edge of
the the farm and we're looking out over
this ridge
and he goes this light comes up and goes
all of a sudden it looked like a like a
a door opening he goes it opened up
three items flew out of it because they
flew they pointed to a bunch of trees
and he goes they flew all over to these
trees and they were right down in the
trees
whatever they were looking for and he
said they stopped doing that and they
flew back in the hole and the whole
closed up and it was gone
so you got a question no this this
particular show
what they were doing is they used a
thermal camera
they brought in a rabbi and this rabbi
began to
say a prayer that was based on portals
that could open portals he said
so as he's going through this prayer
they've got this thermal image camera on
this place
and all of a sudden within mere moments
they have a 27 degree drop
the whole front of the building became
cold and he's now this guy is a he's an
astrophysicist he's like i don't know
what's causing this is the weirdest
thing i've ever seen
so they walk down there the guy's like
dude it's like i walk into a
refrigerator
it's literally that cold here he goes
are we looking at some sort of a portal
i see an eye i think it looks like an
eye is that a portal maybe we're just
only picking up on the residual effects
of it
so there's something again now they're
they're they they're tying it in with
bigfoot they're tying it in with all the
skin walker animals these skin walker
animals have the ability to
change themselves into dogs or bears or
some animal like birds um
and so all these different events have
been going on now they're trying to
figure out a way to to measure this well
they kept finding all these crazy um
microwave that were bouncing all over
the place and some of them were
borderline dangerous
one of the guys they were told hey no
digging on the property
and the guy's like what do you mean no
digging on that's ridiculous this is a
ranch
i got to put poles on the ground this is
ridiculous so he decided one day
i'm i got i got work to do so he starts
to dig a hole
almost the same time he just gets his he
said i got the worst headache
that i've ever had he goes at method got
so bad had to go to the hospital
i got to the hospital had a bump on the
top of my head
he goes the fatty part of my skin had
separated from my skull
and the doctor said i've never seen
anything like this in my life well he
started talking to other guys and he
goes that's what microwave energy will
do to you so somebody was shooting some
sort of a microwave energy beam at you
and hit you in the head and that's how
they got created
so on the last show they started digging
and
they finally realized that some of this
energy was magnetic
and they had they were bringing in
different devices and testing it to see
what it was and they started digging
again and some
weird things starting to started
flashing and he said there's something
moving underground now whether this is
salt water and it's moving particles
but we're picking up something that's
moving and it's moving pretty good
at one point in the show they they
dropped 45 000 gallons of water into
this crack and they don't know where the
water went
and this guy said well this is some sort
of a pathway or maybe it's water
but there's something going on here
that's real so they actually started
digging there and of course that's where
the show ended this week
so it just goes where do you watch this
it's on the history of the history
channel i
i mean is that the one with the guy with
the crazy hair the same
same same channel yeah so like
i tried watching that show like all
these stories sound [ __ ] fascinating
and i wanted to watch it and i you know
i watch a lot of documentaries on this
stuff and when i watched the fr my
problem with it is
i i want to believe it's so bad but then
when i watch an episode of that show on
the history channel
it is just so produced and
safe oh sure and and graphics are the
downfalls
we know what it's like you know we know
what it's like we have experience making
those shows
absolutely done that before like they're
following a schedule they have a crew
where they have like okay at 12 we're
gonna go dig over here
and we got the phone that's gonna go
crazy and we got to do that
i mean there's so there's so much you
have to coordinate
absolutely listen the phone's going
crazy that's that's nothing you can do
like when the guy holds his one phone up
he goes
whatever's happening right now is
getting around my password i think you
could do that
you could do that you could definitely
do that listen nsa can't do it
yeah but you can do it with a video you
can do it you can make a full screen
video on your phone and you can show it
listen okay i get that but listen these
guys are security guys
i could make you one the one guy well
unless i'm again i'm sure there's guys
out there that can do this but again
these
here here's the problem and i agree with
what you're saying they're definitely
telling these guys what to see now the
security guys
are not the sharpest bunch in the group
and the last thing you want these guys
doing is just having some dumbass thing
drop out of his mouth because
yeah that has nothing to do with
anything you say the security guys like
the security guards there security
guards at the ranch yeah they've got
security guards they work at the ranch
they work at the ranch okay
and it's their his basic job was bigelow
is the owner of it now
pull up a clip from on youtube of the
show it's called the skinwalker ranch on
the history channel hold on
hold on are the secrets of skinwalker
ranch i got a clip
but he can play it on the tv so we get
so we could just uh view it sounds kind
of sexy
can i send this to you in walker ranch
the secrets of skinwalker ranch it is
let me tell you dude where is that utah
you said it
is it all inclusive
so like sunnyvale well listen when you
see this guy tell the story
about the dogs getting crushed into the
ground yeah um
those those are facts so there's no way
you can really dress that up
is there photos of it um not so much
photos of it as there is the people who
initially
reported it so there's just reports
correct correct now
and the question is hard to believe
reports well and again listen i'm with
you
even the guy that's out there told you
his name is um he's a he's a
uh physicist astrophysicist
what would you believe
here you go i mean so okay all right
let's see he's the astrophysicist right
there in the background
sure this is his channel this could be a
guy he's one of those guys who made a
bunch of money and he goes how can i
be famous on tv i'll buy the skinwalker
ranch
and i'll sell a show to the history he's
got the money to expose it
that could be it bro but listen but here
now here's the other side of the coin
when the last family that owned the
ranch
they found uh material on the ranch
that was extraterrestrial they took
pictures of it now on the last show they
actually brought up they brought them
into the gun they go so what happened to
these things
we sent them to bigelow but bigelow
won't give it to us back now bigelow
said
make it look like a circus act they they
turn it into a circus well don't listen
don't forget nobody has that perspective
that you do
because of what you of your job so when
they watch us again
what they're trying to do is get the
story across without having too much
drama
so this the story is something's going
on yeah and it has been going on for
40 years 50 years but that's what i that
but that show to me
is like over dramatic size you know what
i mean with the characters
and the names and the music and settings
everything's on tv it has to be
yeah you gotta sell ad space what's that
that's what it's all about is that
nobody's gonna you can't sell the
history channel a boring show well i
mean but you can tell that's what the
history channel is it's just boring [ __ ]
about history it's history channel is
not boring
that's so sick it's it's one of my
favorites man especially i mean like
this is
a few joints watch that channel it's not
better than trailer park boys but i mean
it's
the next best thing yeah but you're not
trying to learn anything
right except for how to retire at 35 by
the way i watched the first episode of
trailer park boys that's the most
mind-numbing show i've ever seen in my
life it's great isn't it it's such a
waste of time
but it's amazing especially if you're
burning the fatty
i get it i get it
[Laughter]